six one seven eight three zero forty
seven fifty let's see who is on the line
from the 703 area code caller from 703
introduce yourself tell us where you're
calling from and what's on your mind
today
hi my name's Matt well I came to been
watching for about a month now and I've
enjoyed everything you've put out so and
my question is Michael Cohen was just in
step three years today what do you think
is gonna happen now what how do you
think toad's could immediately activist
what what to take on it yeah well
Trump's framing has been that Cohen is a
bad guy and that Cohen is lying in order
to get his sentence reduced so I
wouldn't be surprised to see Trump say
should have gotten more time to restate
the fact that there's no collusion to
attack some people on Twitter I mean I
think you're gonna see the the sort of
usual antics from Donald Trump I think
increasingly the question is going to be
okay so Cohen has his sentence and we
now have a better understanding of how
the felonies that he pled guilty to he
was directed to commit by Donald Trump
what's the next step in that trail that
sort of upward pyramid what else does
Muller have who else is going to get
pulled in here so I think I still
maintain that this is merely the
beginning of this entire fiasco yeah I
thought I thought so too
thank you all right I'm a big fan you
know can can you two watch and listen
thank you really appreciate the call
appreciate it great to hear from you